yeah welcome a new blitz game playing
player from the UK Met p does the name
in the day we went c4 c5 g3 so let's um
set up a reverse Grand Prix and he's
playing a line that had been has been
recommended in the books by am Romanian
author marine I think the in in the US
are on England they really called them
calling Marin yeah okay so on in this
kind of position and widest say I think
simply on reproducing the book line that
also looks quite nice for white must
admit I tried for some aggressive set up
with f5 and and so on
so I'm the question is d for Hanks and
he simply doesn't cover it is there some
great justification for this yeah oki
one rookie one is somewhat annoying and
what about F for this one's peace yeah
so I need to sacrifice something now
well just playing all the moves you
learned from a book and don't think
sometimes leads to a disaster all right
so it's a piece for two pounds and can
even take deform yeah i think i should
also why not he's attacking of the porn
now on age six but not sure how bad this
really is Bishop f5 maybe should help to
reduce some some pressure
and if he takes on f5 I take with the
night and actually cover h6 for a moment
at the moment it's an extra piece um
just for a pawn he doesn't even have two
pawns it's just one pawn and when I find
this this piece set up Bishop f5 94
doesn't really look like he's got
something better than exchanging yeah
this one yeah I can take your d3 if I if
I like I don't need to also just 27 seem
some okay also the Queen might help on
the on the seventh-ranked like if he
would done if he takes on age 6 at some
point f Queen g7 I don't even see how he
is going to accomplish that yeah besides
this this this is of course um it was of
course a way
but I've various night moves question is
some night night h4 or well yeah let's
go to to h4 da there should be out of
the simplest so I'm what now f three
years some is hanging in in some lines
can I take on g4 they don't think it's
working the simple way is just to
retreat the night come on let just we
treat this keep it simple I should have
taken with the Queen Queen g5 looks like
slightly out this one some bit annoying
a pin I know c5 looks a bit a bit little
bit awful what the weaknesses but I
cannot cannot accept that is spinning
all the time okay what I need to do is
to I need to get some some activity
niger phones not working 95 people have
this check okay let's go here Oh keeping
an eye on d6 and also preparing to to
activate pieces Quincy 6 Queenie 7 using
the evo I want the night on a form
really
I cannot take Jafar f5 f5 really hard to
believe that smooth as possible okay
this is also not bad it takes only for
rookie fallen there's g for hanging f
for hanging everything f 5 rupee form
takes 26 root g 6 and queen c6 this kind
of things i should have should be ok
okay is not threatening the night so and
some just here and intending 95
let's check on f3 so
all right does the Queen go rook g4s my
next move if you moves the Queen
somewhere and 96 night f3 is just an
extra rock for for not much a couple of
pounds but ok yeah winning endgame the
problem as the time just 19 seconds yeah
here with incremental would be easy
because you you win really relatively
relatively quickly but then I mean it's
easy this is what I'm trying to say but
um the time is really a problem
okay this is a draw but with the time
it's it's okay I'm fine I'll content
relatively I was just just two down too
much too much down on the clock to to
realize that yeah maybe maybe you can
manage 97 for instance here is some
easier okay sixteen seconds sweet
alright thanks for watching